era claro que vai ser fácil é que se
pode fazer em cada grande prémio 4 daí
pra [ __ ] gravadores ele vai sair hoje
uma série por favor valor x da silva 24
foi marca
acorda [ __ ] o que vai ser um foguete de
34 eu tenho de ver o site dos quatro
cantos estava nada
[Música]
o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que seja muito em mim jamais um vídeo e
o estrago de que faz night at freddy's 4
o que é isso não vai ser o jogo
verdadeiro porque supostamente o fight é
fredes 4 vai sair dia 31 de outubro de
2015 ou seja não tiver bruxas pelo menos
foi o que o nosso mix praticar um
estupro no site é preenchimento que é
data do lançamento do novo fight night
at freddy's quatro já tomei uma virose
animatronics e limpar a floresta planeta
cada que as bruxas de que vai ser uma
confusão era bom são três bruxas dentro
do jogo e sei que era aparentemente
estou nessa luta fight night at freddy's
1 mas sem portas tenha que vender
ilusões lado é possível notar que o
google e fred é outra coisa pessoal
a culpa não é do bce permitiu como é que
eu vou para minha sala inicial está não
está a funcionar um deputado também
passava inicial
vamos para uma sala vazia cai como eu
estava dizendo que só no fluminense fred
4 vai ser um novo animatronics que é o
gol do fred mas tipo umas cabeça enfiada
num país eu não sei que aquilo é mais um
ao site que vou deixar na descrição que
vocês vão lá ver a imagem aí tem que
usar o espaço de controle que estão
nesta sala supostamente e eu tenho uma
porta ao meu lado posso fechar mas é tá
do lado esquerdo
isso não faz sentido se eu estou aqui é
a suposta
se o power era fera faixa olha acho que
eu fiz
a próxima que o globo fred ambos tirar
os homens porque eu não interno zernesto
estava no açu está rápido também não ok
ok eu não quero estar à espera
eu só pode vir de sala por isso tem que
ter atenção esta inclusão hoje não tem
nada não conseguiu chegar aqui e espero
que o final de friends 4 não seja algo
do tipo isto porque está uma bosta eu
não sei o que está a passar aqui o time
mandante como fred
eu não saí que está pronto para outra e
os usar isto eu acho que o morro porque
usei está pouco e morrer
os jogos mais três são jogos mais
assustadores e não perceber nada
investiu o seu castanho o fred convence
eu sei que pra baixo
a música é esta temos que apagar o power
power companheiro paulo e ela está acesa
quando falta luz em casa a loja senão
não faz sentido este jogo de amanhã à
tarde quando freire que não acreditava
no meu quarto jequiá a 1 agora não 2
está em baixo e em cima como é possivel
foi roubada
não vai passar o tóxico não quando o
táxi que só viu o orçamento desta sala
tipo jpl
é uma imagem e não consegui enxergar
nada aqui dentro o que é brutal
não consigo voltar a fazer o que agora é
só ficar à espera é que o fc porto já
paguei luxo sul nesta manhã
ainda passar outra vez quero ficar aqui
um pouco à espera da ata la roque ou se
o powers
se o paulo e agora não viu e discutiu
vai parcelar o desconto de 10
lá o que não se vê agora o colégio
estava richie estava a baixar estava a
baixar os custos de fazer a chamada caiu
toxic está subindo muito agora 95 que eu
não topei com o tempo seu power
se o paulo é o primeiro fecharam ou
então o poder da foca ou naquele ano o
google freire aqui dentro
a taxa só são quatro da manhã eu não fiz
por nenhuma e eu consegui passar este
muito bem eu só preciso ter a porta
fechada aparentemente não carregar desta
coisa e não sei qual é o objetivo disto
mas é executar até a china amanhã daqui
eu tô aqui né
é este o cat power pai não quer casar
comigo porque eu to daqui porque tom
castanho
eu agora preciso do bicho e mas só pra
cima do photoshop primeiro não acontecer
nada nada acontece e quando não acontece
não acontece nada
este painel é uma bosta que não sei como
é que eu vou conseguir comentar e esgoto
foque o tiro quando isso finalmente o
status futuro olham por seu eu já passam
a não tocar em cima mas posso também
todo são 21 para minha sala não não há
quem não na que tu não te esqueças que
este jogo é só ficar parado à espera
quatro da manhã pessoal sem fazer [ __ ]
nenhuma só fechar essa porta em aqui
porque é preciso fechar isto anda lá ok
exatamente onde não entram eu não entrou
não sei o que está a passar
eu não sei se estava o gado não está
aqui porque cop menino nós tava ali
houve toque toque grande a cabeça o que
aquele não não não hoje não está só pode
ser uma dimensão minha avó para sair não
dá que não fique contente por jogar uma
bosta é fácil passar então é isso só
espero que tenham gostado eu sei
consultar cima e frank mas para que isso
tenha divertir a mesma já sabem deixa o
nosso leque favorito pra apoiar aqui o
vosso dovizioso largo dos frangos porque
faz vinhos que são compostos por família
por isso chama barco francisco são
preocupantes também então é isso pessoal
fique bem e até a próxima
[Música]